a different perspective on the future is
found at this school in Massachusetts
here the future must start by getting
away from the past the Sudbury Valley
School has swept away everything that's
connected with the beginning of mass
education classrooms timetables and
teachers other traditional schools are
based on the idea that in order for a
person to learn you have to feed him
information information you've
predigested and pre-chosen and that has
nothing to do with the 21st century
where people are really in control of
their own destiny you're saying that
model was created for the Industrial
Revolution
well when the Industrial Revolution
started there were no there were no
schools mass education that was
something that was developed when people
realized that machines back in the early
Industrial Age did not have the kind of
feedback that machines have today you
have to have somebody man they they
could do just a certain amount of the
work and the rest have to be done by
people that meant you have to get people
who are parts of the machine there are
200 on role aged between four and
nineteen and so long as they keep within
the rules they can spend their day doing
whatever they please I don't see any
reason to treat children different from
other people my experience is that
they're human beings just like everybody
else and to view a child certainly after
they become articulate when they can
make some judgment which is usually
about four or five the view a child is
any less competent to make decisions for
themselves then then adults it's
ridiculous we're going to do today the
school is open between 8:30 and 5:30 but
children can arrive at a time that suits
them so long as they stay for five hours
freedom and the be able to do what you
want it's all very nice but what I think
is probably what's helped me the most
recently I've actually met people and
befriended people here who actually
treated me well you know in my old
schools for whatever reason majority of
my friends weren't really friends shows
you uniform oh yes
it also has increased my confidence high
you know there are some people who might
be a bit shocked that you're spending
the school day playing cards bridge is a
good intellectual exercise is like and
there's some math involved and there's a
lot of logic so it's not it's not just a
game it uh it's useful in like learning
and stuff too
I'm making the v scarf this week why um
because I can and I just learned how I
like shake spirits she's really cool
you're happy doing this by yourself
rather than getting in a teacher yeah
it's not that hard it's done listening
to it on YouTube and I'm also reading it
at the same time gives you sort of an
idea of how you should say it what
teachers can do sometimes if a person
wants a specific answer to a specific
question they could give them that but
the most of us in life we go about
learning things I mean you and I and
anybody else really if they think about
their lives they'll realize that most of
what they got out of life they've
learned somehow on their own and they
found ways to to find out what they want
to know rather than have sitting in
front of somebody who's telling them so
you expect Venna child to sort of
stumble across Shakespeare oh well no
not really because they're sitting and
talking and hearing other people stumble
across these things the whole of
humanity stumbled across these things I
mean imagine yourself in Shakespeare in
England you know he wasn't even that
much more famous than the other people
all of humanity has stumbled over time
over over the kinds of things that we
now treasure there's no reason to think
that people won't pick out of all the
world of information new things that
people treasure
there are 11 members of staff employed
by the school we'll keep an eye on the
children and their activities I spent a
lot of time walking around and just
seeing what's going on also that if
people need anything they can find
somebody and get the help that they're
looking for
do they ever ask you any questions oh
sure
sometimes they're you know more
theoretical questions like why are the
leaves turning orange and sometimes it
might be a question about what to do
about contesting a traffic ticket or
pretty much anything another member of
staff is a former pupil who went on to
find success in two separate careers one
as a chef and the other as a rock star
cowboy Mack Bell is on the left as lead
singer with the Joe Perry project James
Brown says I don't want nobody to give
me nothing just open up the door I'll
get it myself that's my philosophy I try
to help maintain the music rooms show
people where the door to the music room
is get them in there and then I kind of
stand back and let them get it
themselves
this is a place where the teachers don't
do it for you there's no workbook to
follow it's really learning in the
trenches which more and more with the
kind of new new business and new
possibilities out there it's a great
experience it's a real experience no I
never wanna break next to the music
rehearsal rooms is an area dedicated to
another popular pursuit video games
could someone explain to me how this
helps you with your learning um I think
I help a little with my reading
abilities when I first came here I
wasn't very good at reading because I
didn't find anything that was very
interesting and when I first came here
the video games pretty much text-based
you had to be able to read to lose them
properly so I basically taught myself
how to read with video games and with
the help of a few interesting plot books
can be found in almost every room in the
school but children are not taught to
read they become literate like
everything else when they want to what
are you working on I'm just a story was
it bad
pupil impairment extends to running the
school whole school meetings make the
policy decisions while a judicial
committee enforces the rules today these
pupils have been charged with chalking
on the pathway in front of the school
the committee decides it amounts to
littering John how do you plea to
littering for draghi
hurroo guilty lilian guilty all right
all right I'll give you them all outside
Nick up next available in four days all
in favor all opposed motion passes
Sudbury Valley is unimpressed by moves
towards greater personalization all
negotiated learning it has to be all or
nothing it's still patronizing its it as
a matter of fact it's worse than the
most traditional and and rigid of the
other schools traditional schools that
are rigid at least ninety percent of the
people go
hate them and they know the enemy a
school that is letting you allowing you
to have a little bit of freedom seduces
you into thinking that a little bit of
freedom where you're really being
manipulated is the real thing and that
opens you to being manipulated all your
life the Sudbury Valley model has been
adopted at more than 30 other schools
mostly in North America but also on a
smaller scale in Denmark Holland Belgium
and Germany nowhere is it considered the
soft option it's the hardest school to
be in and you ask the kids and I'll tell
you it's the hardest school to be and
why
because if you're told what to do or
they it's like taking care of you all
day right you don't have to make
decisions here a kid has to make message
we don't kids aren't happy here all day
the kids are thriving all day and
they're active all day but they go
through all the ups and downs of
mistakes of learning from mistakes of
falling on their face and figure
themselves up again it's a very very
hard existence and I have to prioritize
their time and they have to sit and say
well what is that I really want to do
have to really find out who they are if
current trends continue learners will be
taking much greater responsibility for
their education
if predictions are correct technology
will emerge to support autonomy and
learning at home in school or in the
community personalization and technology
to drivers for change which are coming
together and creating the potential to
revolutionize education for the next
generation it's really a question of
where the personalization line will be
drawn but more importantly perhaps who
draws the line politicians parents
educators or children themselves
you can look further into the future of
learning and teaching and also find a
specially prepared set of tomorrow's
teacher lesson plans and resources by
going to teachers TV /tu